hi this is Daniel Dreyer reading for
danse a sin GameSpot's review of the
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 versions of
WWE 2k15
rey mysterio is one of the great
treasures of sports entertainment WWE
2k15 on the ps4 and Xbox one nails the
production on that let accesing better
than any other game in the franchise but
the character-driven storytelling soul
of the WWE is lost in the process for
those hoping for the tightly crafted
narratives of WWE career modes of
yesteryear leave those expectations at
the door after creating a character you
begin as a fresh recruit at the WWE
Performance Center in Florida and work
your way through the ranks until you
could one day be the WWE Champion and
while this mode lays the groundwork for
storytelling in the beginning it quickly
devolves into an endless series of texts
driven messaging if you're lucky Vickie
Guerrero or William Regal will provide
you with short snippets for why you
should care about your match but more
likely your fight for like any sort of
context son you'll be wrestling purely
for the money and upgrade points every
element of my career mode 182 story
different modes in WWE 2k15 feels
half-baked you have a face he'll gauge
but opportunity to act as a heel or a
face are rare upgrading your characters
to slow a process at first and then goes
far too quickly once you make it to
SmackDown the other better campaign mode
is the 2k showcase focusing on two of
the biggest rivalries in WWE history
John Cena vs CM Punk and Shawn Michaels
versus Triple H its largely unchanged
from the last gen version you fight a
series of matches exploring the most
dramatic moments in these classic feuds
while smart video packages provide
context for your bouts the Shawn
Michaels Triple H food in particular
delivers a rousing act of friendship
betrayal and revenge from start to
finish for those hoping that the gutted
rosters and customization Suites that
blighted the last gen version would be
gone for the new systems sorry
2k15 features the current raw Smackdown
rosters a handful of NXT superstars and
a similarly limited selection of classic
performers the entire create X modes
have been removed from the game
including create a diva create a
storyline create a finisher and more
it's a shame that the stories and
personalities that keep audiences tuned
into wrestling every week are so absent
from my career mode because the series
has never looked better new technology
and a new console generation of led to
night and day leaps forward in terms of
character capture stars like Dolph
Ziggler Randy Orton Sami Zayn many more
stunning with animations that even
managed to capture some of the signature
facial tics not all the character models
are success though superstars with
pronounced facial features become
cartoonish in this new technology and
many characters what large foreheads
seem comically micro proportion in this
game that's nothing compared to
characters with large mouths though such
as the Mazur summer-rae who become
almost monstrous with freaky distended
smiles the in-ring combat is seen nearly
as much of an improvement as the game's
visuals though the new collar-and-elbow
tie-up system for the beginning of
matches adds an interesting strategic
tweak it's the new stamina and health
systems that will totally revamp how you
play WWE 2k15 each character has a
stamina bar and three health bars if you
lose a health bar you drop down to the
equivalent stamina bar if you haven't
fallen there already that ensures that
if you're low at health your character
is now beat to hell and completely worn
out he or she can't move as quickly as
they did at the beginning of the match
which slows their and paced
significantly but also makes matches
more realistic certain wrinkles of
combat are still problematic counters
still refuse to become an intuitive
process - countering attacks it's too
easy to lose all your first stamina bar
if you're at the losing end of the
rock-paper-scissors element of the
collar and elbow tie ups and reversals
do such a disproportionate amount of
damage that it really creates a
disincentive to perform many moves in
your arsenal furthermore though they're
much rarer than we see in the last gen
versions bugs still pop up WWE 2k15
feels much like the modern WWE it is
capable of delivering great in-ring
action and it has the flashy production
values that none of its competitors can
match but it's hard to care about
anything that's happening beyond the
moment-to-moment competition at no point
does WWE 2k15
Janan to something truly special
you're
we'll see you next time